Speaker 1: Hey, this is really just weird, and it
kind of epitomizes stuff we've been talking about
for a long time. I guess there was an event at
Trump's Mar a Lago and at the event. There were
gay supporters of Trump, and I don't want to focus
on why there are gay supporters of Trump, like
obviously it doesn't really make a lot of sense,
although I don't really think Trump is personally
very homophobic or at all, necessarily, but I
think he has chosen to buy in. I don't think Trump
cares one way or the other. Trump cares about gay
people as much as he cares about anybody else,
which is he doesn't. He just doesn't really care
about people, whether they're gay or straight.
But he's certainly done the homophobic transphobic
politics since deciding to run as a Republican,
Republican and getting pulled in to this
reactionary movement. So in any case, there
are gay Trump supporters. Some of them were at
a fundraiser in Florida, and Trump said to them,
You don't look gay. Yeah. Let's look at the clip.
Speaker 3: Oh, thank you very much.
You know, the good. You know, you look good,
right? We did great with the game, probably,
Speaker 1: you know, this clearly, Trump seems
to think gay people have to look a certain way
or that they do. I don't know. This reminds me
of as many of you, if you only there's people who
have no idea what I look like because they only
listen to my show. They don't watch it. I am,
I guess, what's considered white Hispanic like
I'm from Argentina, grew up speaking Spanish
is my first language and then learned English
and OK, you know, so that's that's the deal.
And because I learned English early enough, I
don't have an accent, except when I say certain
words like nuclear and people. When they learn
that I am Hispanic by the definition of the U.S.
Census, sometimes they I can tell they don't even
know they're doing it. They will reflexively go.
Oh, you don't look Hispanic at all. Almost like
they're saying, Oh, I never would have guessed
you were sick. You don't. You don't look sick
at all. Like, it's a compliment that I don't
look what they believe. Hispanic people look
like and I don't, you know, this is not like
the gravest injustice. I find it funny the
reaction that I sometimes get from people.
And it's kind of a similar thing for Trump. Oh,
you guys are gay? Oh, you don't look gay again,
as if that's a good thing. They don't
conform to whatever stereotype of gayness.
Trump would have imagined, and I guess, you know,
when I say when I said earlier, I don't know
that Trump is that homophobic. That's a pretty
homophobic idea, actually, if I do say so myself,
but very strange times at Trump's fundraisers,
and I expect these to get wackier and wackier
as the 2022 election comes forward. Because
Trump is, he seems to be making an effort
to actually support the
candidacies of different people.
And in order to do that, you start to be around a
lot of different people. And Trump doesn't seem to
know how to relate to a lot of different types
of people, which is which is a weird thing. But
apparently, the gay Trump supporters were not
offended. They found it funny. So that's that